all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to the sit down
um before I start make sure you guys
like the video on your way in and
subscribe to the channel we are trying
to get to 2 million by the end of the
year so make sure you hit the Subscribe
button and also hit the like button as
that's the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these streams
so today I have a special guest I have
seen you I was we're just talking I've
seen you all over Tick Tock all over
Instagram I've seen you on sneako stream
welcome Nema to the show thank you thank
you for having me thank you so um How do
you
to think of how to introduce you because
you you do a lot of stuff so how do you
introduce yourself typically yeah you
know uh I I like to create content for
fun okay uh it's uh you know just try to
make some fun content that you know
young men could benefit from uh prior to
that I worked in a private equity in
finance and I still do real estate
financing but but at night I like to you
know during you know outside I like to
have fun and create content okay yeah
but you're I'm I'm you're definitely
doing big pearl like I like you're like
you are the pit of me of like you're
probably really like the number one
female influencer right now you know I
think that's like has like Street love
you know you get Street like you get
like what is Street love
I I think like I'd put you in the class
see okay so like for you to have 1.3
million subscribers
that's not the same to me as if you swam
Downstream playing to Convention okay
like what establishment Netflix
Hollywood wants right so like if you did
that I think you would have had 10
million subscribers
I could have it's the crazy thing yeah
yeah so the fact that you have managed
to get to this point
to me that that you know I think
creators who go that Upstream have less
but they have greater intensity it's
harder because you're fighting for every
subscriber follower you're not getting
promoted by the platform to new
subscribers followers you're not getting
necessarily promoted by views people are
sharing it
and I think it takes greater intensity
to have someone share your content
yeah well it's like you're going against
the mainstream narrative yeah you know
what I so it's like and you're
constantly like being hacked 24 7 for
just going against what the culture
wants
I mean that and that's it you know it's
uh even you see it with comedy uh you
see it with uh politics and uh I you
know have just noticed that like Matt
Rife have you seen his content no and
and I want to just say he does comedy
and if you look at Matt Rife and I and I
respect him I think he's a talented
comedian
at the same point I think because he has
a face
where you could say objectively speaking
is he a transvestite or not no no no but
wait can I Google yeah sure you know
what's his name Matt Rife and and I'm
not I'm not I'm not making fun of him I
I respect him I'm just making this as a
case study because I've I've studied
mattress okay okay so he's he's like a
pretty boy he's a he's I mean he's
objectively handsome he's objectively
nice friendly guy
and objectively you could imagine that
he's a transvestite right like he might
he might be with the lips and everything
maybe not hold on hold on let me just
tell you let me tell you my point let me
just tell you my point that's my point
but like if he makes a joke
or if you and I let's just say we're
having fun would make a joke yeah we get
the same analytics as him back end
shares comments likes excellent
I think because he makes jokes at the
expense of men
and the expensive men looking bad that
he can get 10x 20x reviews
but if you and I make a comment that
women
or specific other community doesn't like
we're completely uh not not getting that
support and and we're getting maybe
violations Etc and so forth and bangs I
mean you and I have been probably banned
you know how many accounts have we like
together been kicked off a lot yeah at
least five for me on Tick Tock maybe
more Actually I don't even know I did a
video last night I didn't do it I have a
small team and one of my guys was like
he hit 355 000 views
I can't even have account on Tick Tock
so I count on myself yeah same yeah I
can't have it they don't give me that
privilege yeah you know uh so so he had
355 000. he's like yo man I got 355 000
views last night
I was like all right cool there's a
response to a lesbian couple I did
and then and then I went to look on it
it wouldn't show up
and that's happened to me more than once
where I see it so there's like a new
sort of Shadow band on Tick Tock where
they hide your content
on to everyone who didn't follow you or
it wasn't shared to it's like next level
and uh I don't think Matt Rife ever
deals with that I think that there are a
ton like for example you're a rich BFF
she's in the business education category
she's a famous supporter for basically
being an influencer going to the Biden
White House let's say Okay far left
liberal by all standards okay
she can put out content that gets a
fraction of the shares of you and I
yet she can get 1.8 million followers on
Instagram get 1 million views with let's
say 2 000 shares that's a [__] joke
about
um yeah you know what I'm saying well
they're pushing them they're pushing
them whereas you aren't being pushed the
way you would have or I would if we were
pushing their narrative well and the
crazy thing is their narrative is evil a
lot of the stuff they put like it's
anti-masculinity it's like teaching
women to be men it's often [__] on
men
um for like and it's just interesting
because the things that like red pill or
like more conservative people promote
are are good but the left I would just
say it's not
it doesn't like promote good it's like
promoting promiscuity promoting like
it's not promoting families it's like
that sort of thing and yet they push
that stuff I would say in about 24 hours
of being here
in London I have probably seen about
20 25
flags for homosexuality
and so bad here yeah literally in about
24 hours I've probably seen
on average maybe one homosexual flag and
I'm not even including hours I slept so
I'm just saying about let's say about 25
hours and I think about it yeah 25 gay
flags
when I got to the airport in London
I saw a photography advertisement to
Showcase what London is
out of the four photos two of them
showed photos of homosexuality
not one fault you're telling me in
London it's not a part of London that a
man my age would have a wife and kids
that's not London but out of the four
pictures describing London to newcomers
two is homosexuality one is like uh you
know a Pakistani kid like having ice
cream and then one is like the street
corner but a tooth homosexuality and
then they'll act like they're not
throwing it in our face when it's it's
literally everywhere I can't go anywhere
not see gay flags like where are my
Straight Flags I want I want a month
dedicated to the straight people that's
where we're going let's let's celebrate
straight straight reality
[Laughter]
let's let's celebrate it but
now I gotta see the and the crazy thing
is I don't even know that many I don't
even know the many gay people yeah
you probably saw more flags for Gay
Pride than the actual gay people yeah I
I really like and what's even more
unique is the combination of like seeing
a group of pakistanis and Indians that
are like religious yeah and then you see
them with a group of gays next to each
other and it's just unique it's just a
unique eclectic mix here that I I don't
remember uh seeing London like this but
London does remind me a lot of New York
uh when I'm in Europe
I would say in the last 30 days three
things that stuck out to me about West
about Europe
one was in Sanford Netherlands I was
walking across the street and I looked
down and I saw like this blue purple
color
I said wait a minute that's odd like the
Avion drink then I looked a little bit
more and I saw the other colors then I
realized that the crosswalk
and you know German zebra striping
you're probably not because you lived in
Germany was was uh was like the LGBT
colors with the Tran colors so they have
it on the street this is in zanford
Netherlands all within the last 30 days
then a few days ago in Spain and
Marbella on the government building they
had Flags they had the EU flag I get it
this the flag of Spain I get it the
local state flag I get it and then the
LG the gay flag on the government
building and they're putting it that
they're implying that it's equally as
important
the country the city the state and gay
people this is all on this it's like you
can't make this
you can't make this [__] is my Straight
person flag what about a flag for
marriage what about a flag for children
and marriage facts man but no and you
know what's interesting I realize how
rare it is for people my age to be like
married and have kids like it's so rare
and I was thinking about the people my
age that like under 40 I would say like
under 35 40 that have been married 10
years it's like it doesn't even exist
yeah yeah they're pushing they're
pushing the degeneracy pretty hard and
then so so there's that one situation in
zanford Netherlands okay there's a
situation in Marbella Spain and in the
situation here where I'm seeing like a
high quantity of gay flags and
advertisements of homosexuality but I
have yet to see one picture that
reflects London which just shows hey
it's just this man a woman and his two
daughters
like really like with all these gay
flags and it's it's just a little and by
the way I have gay friends I have no and
I'm sure you're pretty cool with them
too I have nothing against it's just at
some point we're denying the obvious
that it's just being shoved down right
and at some point
some point
it's just for them
it's for singles looking to get married
in the next year you know yeah like I've
never really seen I've never really seen
that I'll see things pushing like hookup
culture yeah yeah but I don't see
anything pushing families yet they'll
have whole events for gay people where
is the equivalent
yeah it's so if if I were your age I
sound like an old man but if I were and
I see like a 20 year old 23 year old you
know
I'm like wow I'd never remember
uh seeing this so much when I was
younger
you know and I could imagine now how
young men
are are more confused about it you know
and and uh it's it's pretty striking
even social media like it's not really
an equal playing field one it's a it's
really like a hoax
social media is not it really what has
replaced the 90s in the 1990s and 1980s
and 2000 in Hollywood you had casting
directors producers which you still do
and you have directors and their agents
and they're picking and selecting the
actors actresses who will be on the
shows and in the movies
well you see social media platforms it
is almost impossible to get you know a
certain degree of of uh you know
notoriety not notoriety but just you
know recognition if you're not a part of
that program because you do have a team
at these social media platforms that are
picking who's going to dominate fyp and
who's going to be promoted to their new
followers but what's interesting is that
it's sort of a love-hate relationship
because I think that they understand
that the other's engagement is lower so
they're also there's this cognitive
dissonance where they're also competing
with each other
so they will tolerate it enough like
they don't want you and I to completely
leave their platform
because then they lose people on their
app now there's other platforms coming
out Elon Musk I've said this more than
once he was ahead of civilization with
Tesla with his other companies and he's
ahead of he's he's a head of
Civilization by like 10 years by the
significance of purchasing Twitter to be
able to have a platform where left and
right can just have a just talk right
and I don't view Elon Musk as a
far-right guy just because he's not a
liberal doesn't mean he's far right I
just I view him as independent but it's
so crazy because the left has gone so
far that he's considered far right
because because the left has gone so far
but he's not even far right that's like
you're absolutely right I mean just look
at how much he's done for the
environment you know what I'm saying
like it's hard it's like
at least he's giving the liberal you
know what I respect the bottom a lot is
that at least at Twitter
you know
the liberal can say some degenerate
stuff but he permits it
but on Instagram and I and I know we're
on YouTube but I'm just saying on the
other platforms
they're not going to permit it you know
what I mean at that level a lot of stuff
will not get promoted the way it could
be
you know it's it's it's much harder
fault
so how did you get into this space
so when I was in Germany uh during the
lockdown I put some videos up in it and
it went and I went by it went viral what
were the viral videos about talking
about uh
they were just like they were more like
business education videos okay and then
uh and then from there I just noticed
after a while like people are like
what content should you make to do well
on social media if you want to create
content on social media
I think it's pretty I mean you do it
really well but I would say just look at
what video out of 50 videos what videos
did the best right right so like I
wanted to do just crypto blockchain
Finance content because I was coming
from private equity and and I and then I
realized that the videos that I was
you know playing around more did the
best so then I just did more of that so
where are you from originally New York
did you say I lived in New York about 15
years okay New York City and where
before that like where were you yeah
yeah so I lived I lived in I lived in DC
I lived in uh I lived actually lived
here for I lived in Europe for about a
couple months prior to getting a home
here for the last few years
uh and I lived in DC I lived in Atlanta
L.A
New York but New York City is where I
lived the longest about 15 years okay
and is that because you're in you said
Finance private Equity I did yeah but I
also worked in the nightclubs okay so I
was working for about 10 years I work
with fashion models in New York City
nightclubs wow yeah yeah so I was going
I would go to castings
and I would meet the women
and I would get their number I would
exchange information and then I would
invite them out to the nightclub and
then I would charge a fee for bringing
them out and it was a good situation
because the women wouldn't feel
obligated to owe me anything
and I would get a fee from the from the
nightclub so I would charge like a
thousand dollars let's say
bring like eight models
and then I bring like five ten other
women who weren't models but tall
generally speaking uh or pretty and and
uh and then it's like I bring like 10 15
people like a crew we would take a table
we get bottle service
that's where I learned a lot about women
okay that was really like my PhD in
understanding women because my women
were essentially my entire clientele I
didn't get paid to bring guys I only got
paid for bringing well I'd imagine too
you have to learn so much dealing with
like the top 10 20 of women in terms of
likes I'd imagine if they're in New York
modeling they're probably top would you
say 20 of Beauty in the world right yeah
yeah so it's like those are the women
that have so much sexual agency and
sexual power so much more than the
average chick so it must have been
interesting to see like what they did
with it
like dude would you say that those women
When selecting like boyfriends were did
they typically select like good
boyfriends did they sleep around like
what did they do with does that question
make sense with all that like power in a
way yeah
um
I think a lot of men and you know
just for the record uh you know
you guys just so you know I'm not lying
like you could go on New York Post New
York daily news and see that in around
2012 2013 I had a Monday night party
okay and that was Peak because that was
a party where the supermodels Victoria
Secret models
Hollywood celebrities billionaires would
actually come it was known as the top
party in that New York in that in that
period I didn't keep it for long
nightclub ended up closing but just to
get to that point is top of the Pyramid
of New York nightlife that's very hard
to get to
so I was able to see a lot
and one thing I saw
was how some men could be so good at
making money
but bad with women yeah yeah and I would
see it over and over and over and over
and over again to the point where I was
mystified at hey man I wish I back then
I didn't make much money bro so I
thought
how can this guy and these are not
necessarily all dorks you know what I'm
saying dorks I don't like calling
anybody a dork but just a dorky
character right okay uh
and he
was very good at making money
and you know he had the material items
but with the women he was a complete
idiot like it was like that part of his
brain didn't work you know it was sort
of like a guy that's great with
computers but he doesn't have sales
ability or a guy who's great with sales
but he can't cook he can't fix a tire
if it goes flat you know he can't put
Furniture together but he's a great
salesman he doesn't know how to fix the
computer those guys so would they be
sexless or would it be more like they
just couldn't keep women
I think a lot of them would struggle I
think a lot of them would struggle to
get women I think a lot of them would
become bitter that
um
you know that they would get played and
I think a lot of them I think it's hard
for a lot of these guys to be honest uh
because I think that they face the most
viciousness when they're out at New York
City nightclubs it's tough to get women
you know it's also easy to get women
because there's a lot of women but it's
also nasty it's cold and I would
approach women at a casting so that's
like one o'clock on a Tuesday you know a
Spring Street in SoHo
their models coming out for like two
hours I'm going up to them like talking
to them or right there in the street and
I'm you know about six three guys you
know I'm Middle Eastern I'm a dark guy
these girls are coming from like
Russia they're coming from like Poland
Ukraine they've never seen a dark man
like me before and the ones they have
were the ladies guys that take the women
and go to Eastern Europe
you know they have a name for that and
uh I'm not gonna say it but so they may
have viewed that I was trying to do
something like that there was that
stereo type of men like me
so I'm approaching them right in the
street there's no music there's no
Ambiance and I would have to be able to
get them get their phone number and then
invite them out to a nightclub then I'd
go pick them up with like a car take
them out to a nice dinner right the best
restaurants would like a lot of the best
restaurants with compass and take them
out so imagine the power of going up
with like models from IMG Ford next in
New York you know that's that's High
Caliber models New York and Paris you
know these are girls that modeled in
Paris London New York Milano Tokyo and
you go to the nightclub and then you see
a table they would put me right next to
another table five ten fifteen thousand
dollar table
service guys spending money that guy
spends fifteen thousand dollars and the
girl won't even look at them you know
what I mean right so like so they would
get attention from women but it would be
very like
like the the girls were kind of using
them basically the guys that were like
bad with checks anyways but you know
this this gets even there's even another
facet there's so many there's Dimensions
to this so so the Brazilian models
these are all called This is
generalizations first of all I mean you
have to yeah you can have a conversation
about anything without generalization
yeah well well because it's fascinating
because like everyone everyone gets mad
over them oh you can't generally well
you can yeah yeah I mean yeah you know
yeah yeah so so to the Brazilian models
okay would have tension with the Russian
models
and like if they would have these model
Apartments where maybe there's one part
of them a Russian one part of them are
Brazilian it's not always exactly like
this but this is a general idea
and what I noticed was that the
Brazilian models in general were much
more easy going relaxed
more open whereas the Eastern European
models
were more traditional
they didn't give a [__] how a man looked
they cared way more about money about
money okay but they were also in that
way like treat me like a woman you're
gonna do this this this and this for me
but in return I will do X Y and Z for
you
and okay with being a traditional woman
and being submissive
and I thought that was more honest than
someone that was even if I didn't like
it I think that that's more honest than
saying I do want x y and z
but I but when it suits me I also want
this right you know like yeah I'm happy
to
to you know have these benefits of being
independent but then but then when the
when the tab comes I want you to pay
and which one is it I'm curious did they
end up getting married like I'm just
curious like the women because you're
how old you're I'm 42. so you're 42. so
I'd imagine how old were you when you
were doing this
man I was I was like in my 20s early 30s
okay so now you can kind of see like
what happened to them like if if it
ended up good or bad so I'm just curious
do women in the top 20 of beauty tend to
get married or do they waste their
beauty
I will find that a lot of the fashion
models that would come out
to the nightclubs after two three years
A lot of them drop off
and uh and I think that what happens is
a lot of them settle down okay I do
think a lot of them would settle down I
think I think when you're in your early
20s that's just you're raging you know
like me in my 20s
working five nights a week throwing
parties right
it was impossible for me to settle down
until my late 30s so when I see young
men talk about going out being with
women
I get it you know it's do I think it's
degenerate Yeah but I
I'd be a hypocrite if I if I attacked
them for sleeping around with a bunch of
women not being in a relationship
um
I've become a traditional man because
you became a traditional man yeah I'm 42
years old you know I'm I'm I do believe
in a monogamous relationship I am
against adultery I never make jokes
against about adultery or [__] that
I'm a homosexual because I don't I think
I would never make a joke that I'm
homosexual or that I cheat on my wife
because that's my dog because how my
daughter one day will get older
and I don't want my daughter to ever say
to me why'd you cheat on Mom
you know my daughter is the most
precious thing to me in my life you know
and my relationship with my
wife is the most important relationship
in my life I put her front and center
but my wife is traditional
you know she's a teacher by training
she's a college graduate she's a teacher
by train her mother is traditional her
grandma in German they call it Oma she
was traditional her sister is
traditional where I live in Germany
where I have a home
it's traditional women
and these are women that are great at
keeping the home organized cleanliness
preparing meals and their happy this way
this is this is this is was this was
crazy to people in the United States
maybe if you live in a small City
and by the way my wife is not from New
York I didn't meet her in a New York
nightclub from a small City and even
within a small City in the most rural
part of that small City we got cows
horses and pigs in my neighborhood in
Germany where I have my home
so over there the women it's almost a
cultural norm in that part of Germany to
be married
have one man
you're cooking cleaning
and it's not outrageous to say it
they actually want to do it and they
take pride in it
but demand works he takes care of it and
for my from my wife her mom her grandma
her older sister
her cousins her aunt she has so many
examples and that's actually a pretty
well balanced lifestyle yeah well and
what I realized is like we have a whole
generation especially in the west a
whole generation of like people that
don't know how to be wives or or
husbands honestly for that matter but
and I realized it's because women lead
most relationships so most people if
they've seen uh their parents already
gathered the mom probably led the
relationship not the man because of I
think the way that the Contra the I
think it's because of the way marriage
is like the contract is in the U.S where
like women are basically rewarded for
leaving so the guy's always going to be
trying to make the girl happy and we
have a whole generation of women that
have worked so like how are you gonna
have traditional skills if you're
working
and then and then I mean I didn't even
scratch with like single mother homes
right so it's like how would women how
would we know how to be wives and
mothers if we've never seen it it's
interesting you really wow
wow you know what uh it's interesting
you say this about single mothers
because I had for a while I lived with
my mother and my parents split mm-hmm
and I think one reason a lot of men
sleep around with women
and this is something that's not really
talked about
you know a lot is that they maybe men
also have issues with their mother the
way some women have issues
you know with their father oh yeah you
know oh yeah you know like there was a
you know a lot of men you know you know
yeah so
a lot of people look at me and they
assume that
you know I got a lot of [__] in my past
and they would be right
okay so so my friend once said to me
alphanima
how would you how would your mother feel
if she knew how awfully you treat women
and uh and I said to him I looked at him
and I said
I don't give a [__] what she thinks
about me
because that woman it felt like she
never really gave a [__] about me
and
you know
the one thing she was good for
was the milk
and her titties
and that's actually Alpha King rule
number 88. if you want to build strong
men when they grow up who treat their
women like Queens
set a good loving example for them
when they're young
well and the other thing
and playing about the way men treat them
but it's like traditional women don't
typically have a problem getting
traditional men
you know
the thing is that
you said to me why was it I became
traditional what you said to me earlier
I became traditional you're right I
became traditional okay you're right I
became traditional yeah I think it's
learn you can learn it yeah
but one reason I wasn't traditional
was because when I was working in the
nightclubs bringing out all these women
it wasn't until after I became
traditional that I realized perhaps it
was a sex addiction
that I was sleeping around with so many
women and it wasn't until my 40s that I
start confronting the fact that
hey maybe in my 20s and 30s I didn't get
that love from my mother
you know and and and then I was [__]
a lot of women
but there was something missing
you know maybe that's why I spent so
much time in New York City nightclubs
I was just fanatical about getting [__]
constant you know and and that's you
know there's something dirt do you lose
it my friend said this to me
my friend you know and uh I'm not gonna
say who he is you know but but
well-known guy he said to me he said
every every woman and he you know he
said every woman you sleep with
it's like you're losing a piece of
yourself
and and and I thought I thought it was
towards before I met my wife in my late
30s
but it was around that point where I was
like it hit me it was the right word at
the right point in my life
um it's hard if you're a man and your
mother is called to you
that's that's some [__] that that's some
it hits your heart now some guys the
guys who have mothers like that and the
mother loves them
but the guys that have gone through that
I would imagine that they would
understand what I'm saying the same way
a girl yeah whose father ignores her doc
can you imagine that I love my daughter
I couldn't even imagine I couldn't even
imagine if I just deserted her
how could she feel about man so when I
see a woman act like a [__]
you know now I'm not talking about
before right when I was Kingsdale when I
was these other guys age you know no no
when I was young
if I saw a woman act like a [__]
I might have been like all right cool
let's have fun
because I was also a [__] I was also a
promiscuous but now as a father with a
daughter
I think [__] when she was a baby when
she was a baby
her father deserted her you said
something to me Pearl you said I moved
before you said
I want me to blow you up I know you're
okay you know you said something to me
that I understood your father without
knowing your father
you said to me I I went back to living
at home with my parents yeah right and
my and then you said your feelings your
mom's sentiment but then you said my dad
was so happy yeah I understood that
because I'm already looking forward to
tomorrow and I get back to Germany my
daughter being there at the airport and
I've only been gone a week but it's been
all I miss her I miss my wife and the
point I want to make is that
that feeling of when you go back in a
later next month or this month to go
back to Chicago and meet your dad he's
going to be so happy to see you
I know that feeling because I also have
a dog you don't know what it feels like
to be a man and have a daughter I do
it's impossible for you to understand
that
as a man as a father you'll never be a
man or a father I am both
he will be so happy to see you the same
way I'm going to be happy when I see my
daughter tomorrow
you know because you imagine if you
didn't have a father there tomorrow next
week two three weeks from now when you
go back to the United States to pick you
up he didn't give a [__] about well and
it's awesome yeah I mean it's also like
when you're close with your dad you
like even me I quit like drinking a
couple years ago and part of it was
because of my dad because my dad doesn't
drink at all and so it's like I don't
know you just kind of do things like
make your dad happy because it's like if
he's you don't want him to be
disappointed you know so I mean just
look how happy you were well it wasn't
being recorded but even when it wasn't
being recorded
how happy you were when you you were
elated when you said
oh my father he was really happy though
when I came back yeah right he was right
like yeah but but see how happy you how
happy you were he was happy and then you
were happy right because you feel that
you are accepted you feel loved you feel
like you feel welcomed you you felt
welcomed accepted embraced you felt safe
to go back home
like not just not just he you could go
back but you genuinely felt warm and
welcomed you felt a warm welcome imagine
if you didn't have a father you know
that you know what I noticed when you're
talking about like mommy issues well I
can hear it in a guy's voice if he
doesn't grow up without a dad a lot of
times I'm it's not a hundred percent
yeah but I don't really know I can't
really describe why I can just like tell
usually they have a slightly like higher
tonality and they kind of speak like a
woman they they use like a lot of hands
when they talk like there's just certain
like mannerisms you kind of pick up on
especially when they're younger guys
especially
um but one thing I noticed was that a
lot of times when guys have a visceral
reaction to like defend uh promiscuity
or defend like
uh single mothers to diff because you
know you know and the red pill space
you'll say like don't date single
mothers don't date [__] you know just
basic stuff and I'm like why do I get
this visceral reaction from the Met like
they should agree with like there's a
group of men that just should agree on
this stuff but what I realized is that
they're defending their moms a lot of
them because that's who
it's true you don't raise them no I'm
sorry no no good that was it but go
ahead oh no yeah it's uh
you know like anyone can fact check me
like I out of out of respect for my wife
I don't put my ex-girlfriends who are in
Vogue magazine but if you were to go on
Google and put my name and go Google
Images you will see at least two of my
ex-girlfriends who are in Vogue magazine
I was here in London I lived in London
for a little less than two months
because my ex-girlfriend was modeling in
London so
that's my resume in understanding women
you know I literally through parties
bringing a lot of fashion models that's
hard imagine getting one fashion model
imagine getting eight I had to and I'm
not Brad Pitt so I'm not I'm not Johnny
Depp I'm not I'm not GQ model so I
really and I'm not and I wasn't Rich so
I really had to figure out how to talk
to women to be able to get women to come
out I have nothing to prove and I'm also
a happily married man and I love my
daughter I'm a loyal man to my wife so
I'm looking I talk about the game
like a lot of my Alpha King rules and
stuff like that that's me when I was a
bachelor
now I'm in my 40s but I still live that
that lifestyle and and when I see men a
lot some of this stuff Pearl
it is immaturity
also some of the men
that talk a certain way
and women
some of it is just maturity it's it's
not I also set stuff in my 20s and you
know what I mean or Mata I also said
stuff that I might not feel now today
you know some of the guys maybe didn't
get love from their mom
and they're also not getting love in the
nightclub
they're also not getting love from the
girl in their college
they're just not getting love in general
from a woman no wonder they're [__]
bitter
right or to order girl
her dad doesn't give a [__] about her
she goes to the nightclub she gets drunk
she gets [__]
he doesn't he doesn't call her anymore
or he just tells her hey come over
that's it just come over
come on she wants she wanted you think
you think during the holiday during her
birthday she didn't wish she had a
father or boyfriend
She's suffering she's struggling you
know same with the dude
I had a great relationship with my dad
he's a very traditional man my dad to
this day
it's you know he it's it's crazy like I
went out with my wife and this lady that
he's with my dad's a little bit of a
Playboy now but he's traditional in the
sense of when we went out he refused to
let me pay
he refuses to let me pay for meals when
he's with us what a woman
it's traditional in that right
you know
so
I had a great relationship with my dad I
do with my mom I love her so much but I
also have accepted for some people in
your life
uh it's okay to love some people from a
distance maybe I know my mother loves me
I love her
but I think we've both realized it's
okay to love each other from a distance
and appreciate if we can just have one
you guys like fell out or something
all right it's just it's just hard yeah
it's just it's just really hard and and
and not enough you know
I think when you lie
on social media or you lie on TV right
you're really just showing you're a
coward
you know like it's showing like like if
you're a man and you're not
acknowledging you had issues oh okay it
takes more bravery to show
you know that stuff you know like
yeah like I I handled
my mommy issues by [__] a lot of
women
right in my 20s and 30s that's a fact
like
people will say oh you have mommy issues
yeah I did and that's how I handled it
[__] a lot of women do I what would I
have done differently I would have gone
to therapy to be honest
someone will say oh go make money go to
the gym I already did those two things
I already did those two things okay but
what else well how about my mental
health the gym cannot cure all mental
health issues working making money
cannot cure all mental health issues
that's something I know that's popular
on social media I disagree with that I
think you can work hard make a lot of
money go to the gym these are good
things that can help you but there's
guys that commit suicide there's guys
that are that are suffering from
depression
they can't get out of it they're trying
they're working out six days a week
they're making money they're still
suffering
yeah I think a mental health
professional and faith can help anybody
you know and I think if you're going
through something hard
get some help
I don't think there's any shame in that
I wish I would have spoken to somebody
earlier about my issues with my mom
instead of [__] so many women don't
think it really necessarily I just
delayed growing up
right well see the issue though
with therapy nowadays is don't you think
there's so many crazy therapists my
therapist was a gay man who was a Bernie
supporter yeah who became a trump
supporter and he's he was a do you make
him a trump supporter is that you no no
he was already here
he was a trump supporter and uh I just
thought it was he was nothing nothing
conventional he was unconventional
nothing against like therapy as a whole
I just I've actually I went to school
for psychology this year
um because that was part of like the
volleyball program like they gave like
when I came here they gave me like free
school with it basically
um I didn't end up finishing it because
this kind of got too much for me to
handle but I just saw the women becoming
therapists and I was like Jesus Christ
these are who is helping people they're
nuts they're crazy yeah yeah so like how
does a guy differentiate the difference
between a good one and a bad one because
I'm just saying first-hand experience
I've been in school people becoming
therapists God they're nuts they're so
crazy like
yeah no no I understand and they
indoctrinate you in the schools too it's
like wild
the thing is is that now education has
become like something else crazy yeah
like I would say like I graduated high
school 1998.
so in 1990 in the 1990s I was born 96.
yes
yes you were born in 1996 yes yeah I was
in high school
yeah I was in high school November 4th
that must have been a good day for you
the world was graced with me oh man yeah
it was a great day yeah it was a lot of
sunshine yeah yeah I'm sure it was
someone was elected that day it was my
birthday I don't know who well back in
1996 1997 the idea of you know being a
man and woman having marriage that was
that was normal yeah so now I can
imagine how how the people in 2023 my
therapist was like
you know 60 years old like 60 maybe 55
60. so in his generation it might have
been even more traditional yeah uh but
but uh I could imagine the ones now in
2023. so so you you want the same
education
what do you mean oh just now high school
now and college now is not how it was in
the 1990s it's become very very very a
lot well it started before that when
they subsidized education in the 60s
that's when you start to see the drop
off in test scores okay when like they
made college free and then they put all
the woke stuff in the colleges uh okay
it's gotten way worse though I will
agree it's like way it's it's definitely
not the same but it did start in like
the 60s 70s well I never remember
uh in high school or middle school or
Elementary School seeing like you know
gay sex oh no it's way worse now yes
yeah like I never remember that yes at
all but even like sex had as a whole I
don't know if that was around when you
were in the 90s but that was like one of
the things they put in schools because
think about it they start with sex and
they add sex like they start with sex ed
then they add in the gay stuff but we
didn't have gay stuff we had sex ed yeah
but we didn't have gay stuff yeah but
even the sex said like that's kind of
part I think anyway that's like part of
the indoctrination they do that now
though right yeah yeah
well I mean I I've heard that was like
before even like I heard that was in the
90s too really I don't maybe where I was
if they didn't have it no no honestly
but so I would tell you if they did yeah
but so so you did in New York you did
you worked in finance yeah then you you
screwed a lot of chicks
that was because but but it was also
like the environment you know like
you're working at a nightclub you're
working at popular nightclubs yeah you
got 20 year olds that want to go to
nightclubs no no judgment I'm just yeah
yeah I'm just saying back what you told
me so so you screwed a lot of chicks you
know
um and also we're working in finance and
at the nightclubs Finance I did later I
met I I got into Finance okay from
because I was working and met a lot of
billionaires okay literally you know and
uh
you know just some of the wealthiest
people in New York because they were the
ones that could afford a five ten
thousand fifteen thousand dollar table
not just from New York all over the
world and then I met somebody I worked
in hedge funds and then from there he
got into private equity and then he said
he was a zerk Switzerland he was like
why don't you come and work with me
because I know you got to roll the decks
and that's how I got in and he traded me
okay that's how I got it but you got and
you got your PhD in women you'd say from
the nightclub definitely model okay so
now you get you give dating advice right
to guys
well pick up I saw one from you that was
like
oh I can't remember what it was but I
thought it was so good I just remember
thinking that is it's actually bothering
me I can't remember what it was I saw
like a day ago too but you give all
these like tips and tricks to like build
attraction with women you'd say yeah
yeah you know I try to I try to I try to
focus on everything you know I try to
focus on the entire entire
entire just I just think there's not a
lot of young men or somewhat young
midlife that are able to talk to young
men that have let's say 20 years of
business experience like in real life
right in real life I am a sober man
I don't smoke I'm loyal to my wife and
uh and I'm 42 year old and I'm an
executive you know and and I but I'm
able to make content that a lot of I
find a lot of young men like
so I feel like all right well why don't
I put some life lessons in there
uh that you know that that I've learned
along the way you know I'll give you an
example okay great
that was my next question so you beat me
to it no go ahead no no I was gonna ask
for an example so oh okay well a lot a
lot of people think I'm misogynistic
because of my view me too
I think I might be a little bit though
so
well on gender roles okay yeah yeah
I believe that if a man goes out all day
long and works hard to support his
family
the least his woman can do
is make them some dinner
at night
but
the same logic could also apply
to men
if you sit at home all day long playing
video games
while your [__] is out at making much
more money than you
then you should basically learn how to
suck some cot
because you're basically the [__] at
this point
right yeah so so that's Alpha King rule
number 202 which proves that Madame
misogynist yeah because remember
it's not having a [__] that makes you a
[__]
it's acting like a [__] that makes you
a [__]
so when you think about it it's all it's
all it's all like what are you doing so
it's like this this there's two sides of
the coin
okay you want to be a traditional man
you'll get your ass up make money like a
[__] man and take care of her
if you can't do that you can't like I've
been in a relationship with a woman who
made more money than me more than one in
fact this is my first my wife is my
first girlfriend where I made more money
because I didn't make money most of my
life Pearl
I didn't make much even if I made two
three thousand dollars a week in New
York New York's expensive right you know
so like it wasn't until I met my wife
that I finally had some I broke that
Weekly paycheck
it wasn't until by the way my wife met
me before somebody says oh my wife's
with me for my money I met my wife at an
Airbnb on a Spanish Island I was renting
the smallest bedroom the landlord said
oh there's two German girls in the other
room I had the smallest bedroom I was
backpacking I'm a little bit of a hippie
she didn't know I'm doing private equity
she might have thought I was a writer a
bartender
she but she wanted to talk to me and she
saw me as a guy just renting a tiny
bedroom backpacking through Europe
literally backpacking through Europe
I said I was like that woman is for me
you know
and I loved that she was from a small
village and I was like all right that
woman is for me but you wanna know what
I take care of everything
you know
she has my credit cards
she uses it she doesn't you know my wife
imagine imagine you've been with a woman
for four years five years
not once has my wife asked me to buy her
a Celine bag
not once since my wife asked me to buy
her a Hublot Big Bang watch
Rolex
not once in fact she doesn't even care
she does it she genuinely doesn't like
sometimes I tell her go get something
this [__] comes back I'm like what the
[__] is this Zara bag she's like God is
what I wanted I felt that way she goes
to some German store where she gets the
80 year old dress which is like 85 USD
I made this all you wanted
doesn't care
and and I think like to me cool but do I
make sure we have organic food
yeah I insist on getting stuff like that
because I don't want her to worry about
making money
but she has a full-time 24 7 job there's
not one woman that could watch this that
won't understand what I'm about to say
and that's that being a mother a real
mother a dedicated mother a warm mother
a loving mother that's loving you know
caring that's a 24 7 job because when
your baby is crying at 3am in the
morning
is she gonna wake up with a [__]
attitude
or is she going to wake up with a
patient loving
attitude of warmth of all my daughters
crying my son is crying I'm gonna take
care of my daughter
3 A.M it's 5 a.m your daughter's crying
again she wakes up with a good attitude
6 a.m your son is crying your son the
father can't do anything I can't do
anything when my daughter cries Pearl I
can't do it I'm useless all my IQ all my
money all my intelligence
means nothing when my daughter's crying
because she only wants the mother's
touch the warmth of her mom's tit
and that's the superpower my wife has
she's a traditional woman
right like okay cool I take care of her
I take her on vacations we do Luxury you
know we do a lot of things but she never
asked me for money like that only she
really she's very she's so that's you
get a traditional woman a lot of these
degenerate stuff goes away a good I
guarantee you if you have two people man
and woman
both traditional
they have a family
yeah it's going to have you're going to
have some problems you're gonna have
some issues we're human
but
I would say that those two who have a
family are generally more happier in
their 40s and 50s
than the people who are just behaving in
a degenerate way in their 40s and 50s
when you're being doing this stuff in
your 20s and 30s it's cute it's fun
but then when you get older
you're going to see your friends get
married and have kids
you know and you're going to see your
friends actually there's stability there
there's security there it feels good
waking up in the morning and seeing your
wife or your husband next to you that
you know that brings me happiness when I
wake up and I see my wife
makes me happiness when I play with my
daughter in bed the happiest part of my
entire [__] day is it that morning
I'm playing with my daughter and I see
my beautiful wife
to me that's like thank God I woke up
thank God really I think thank God like
this is be I'm so happy I got to
experience this because I could die
today die tomorrow but at least I got
one more morning to experience my
daughter
kiss her face pinch her cheeks
you know
traditional is not as bad as you think
like not you you get it but
people have this com this confusion that
like my wife is like oh she's in the
kitchen making a meal she's happy doing
it she loves cooking
my wife loves cooking she actually likes
being a housewife
that's and by the way my wife
is a German
Western Europe we're not talking about
Iran or my dad is from
you know hey
you know we're talking about Western
Europe
where do you think guys can find
traditional women because that's a
complaint is I always hear is that
there's no traditional women left like
where do guys find traditional women
or do you think they have to make
someone into a traditional woman
that's another thing I've heard that
like you can't like find the perfect
wife you have to make the perfect wife
man that's a good question yeah uh
oh [__] man
no because I was even talking I was
talking to King about this the other day
I was like what percent we've had hun
like how many guests have we logged here
so like because we started logging
guests like a couple months ago so three
four months ago we've maybe had what 600
700 in the system and this doesn't even
count
um we just started like logging them
like we I probably had way more come
through here and we're thinking like how
many traditional women out of all these
hundreds of women that have been here
and I was thinking I don't even think 10
like I think I would I would say maybe
five I could think maybe
yeah yeah you know and I don't say this
to be insulting right I'm not saying
they're bad people I'm not saying this
is like but I was thinking about it I'm
like can you really have a traditional
woman over the age of 25 because like
traditional women get like that means
you think the family comes first so if
you make it to 25 and you're not married
like in a way you can't be traditional
and I'm 26 so I would include myself in
this right like I was playing volleyball
in my early 20s that's not what
traditional women do they get married in
their early 20s
yeah you know so that's what I was
thinking about this the other day so
like if a guy wanted to get married to a
traditional woman like where where would
he go
especially in this culture
you know
as a man who's been in the game and a
man who's now married
I would say one thing that I would think
is makes a good woman
is when she talks about her father
uh not to say a woman is not good if she
doesn't talk well about her father
but if a woman talks well about her
father and her and their relationship
that tells me at the bare minimum
she had a good role model
and probably at the bare minimum
she's not gonna permit you to disrespect
her
the likelihood is probably much smaller
than if she had a bad relationship and
that was one thing I saw firsthand
repeatedly am I like about a decade of
working with fashion models in New York
City nightclubs the ones that behave
like [__]
maybe nine out of ten occasions
yeah but it kind of it all goes back to
the family Dynamic right because even
you you were saying that like a lot of
um when you were sleeping around it was
because
um you had mommy issues and you see the
same thing with daddy issues and it's so
interesting because we have a higher
standard of living than ever before but
we have so many mental problems because
the family unit is not intact anymore
and it's like even if people grew up
with married parents how many were
arguing all the time couldn't get along
it's like I genuinely think my
generation is afraid of traditional
outcomes in marriage because of what
we've seen from previous generations
yeah yeah I mean and in that in that 10
years I I mean I I it was startling to
me but I remember that a lot of the
girls that I felt uh were the most
conservative that were the most
traditional in the sense of they're not
going to be act like Horrors
um
they they had good relationships with
their dad I'm not saying it and then all
I'm not saying every single situation
but more often than not if a girl had a
good relationship with her dad he was
checking in with her you know while
she's in New York
he cared gave a [__] she was much less
likely and also many of those girls I
think were also probably much less
likely to even go out to a lot of
nightclubs yeah
so I was probably seeing the women who
were already in that way broken you know
that would like to party the party girls
are the ones I generally met yeah we're
the party girls that was the pool yeah I
mean it's also like modern men and
modern women kind of find each other
right where it's like because I I do
know because when I think of like the
stereotypical traditional woman I think
of a girl that's a virgin on her wedding
day right yeah and it's kind of crazy
because I was curious I'm like what
percent of women actually wait it's only
five percent
so that means I'm like there's only five
percent of women that I would say like
TR like actual traditional right and I
was thinking of the women I know that
did that and I was like they got married
at like 21 22 like two traditional men
in churches
yeah that's that's a it's a very small
like subset obviously like I've had
hundreds of women here I think there was
one girl that I believe was a virgin you
know yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
the other ones kind of just lie it's
like very obvious but
what do you see what do you see in your
experience what do you mean like just in
general like for traditional women and
men like here in London how do you see
it I I don't think they really exist
traditional women not in the cities
anyway
um I'd say like in small like church
subsets I'll see more traditional but
it's really interesting because a lot of
women still don't have like the
traditional mindset like if I said do
you uh do you obey your husband
it's still like oh well maybe and so
that's how like I can kind of test where
a girl's mindset is if she believes in
like true biblical submission
which is like you're supposed to obey
your husband yeah you know yeah and the
thing is is like
my wife is pretty pretty traditional
yeah but I don't abuse it right right I
don't abuse it it's it's it sounds crazy
to people when you talk like this yeah
but it's it's not it there are many
people who have like my wife is free
she's a liberal you know she's actually
a liberal yeah you know and she's a
college graduate and she lives in a
wealthy country yeah Germany yeah and
her father is a CEO in the auto sector
but she's also a traditional and she's
happy being a housewife yeah you know
it's like this is It's like a myth of
like
and so it's like a and it's like a myth
almost like we're talking about the
Stone Age we're talking about women that
are from like you know this third world
country where you know they're not able
to talk that's not the case yeah well
we've had like a hundred years of
propaganda
yeah so it's like we've had 100 Years of
propaganda saying if if you submit to
like one you always have to have a
backup plan
so like I've even had girls come on and
say they want backup houses
you imagine like a backup house like
just in case the man goes wrong and
starts abusing you one day oh my God
like this is like think about how the
gut reaction to whenever we talk about a
lot of hot button topics it's always the
man's an abuser or a gripest like it's
always those two things like this is the
propaganda in the culture that you see
where they just paint men as either one
idiots and the woman's the smart one or
two they paint them out as abusers that
will which I honestly think that women
abuse men more than men abuse women yes
yeah yes I do I think it just the men
are like they don't want to go to the
police and say and say yeah this is just
anecdotal just my opinion right yeah
yeah but in my opinion I just think like
we have a hundred years of propaganda
saying you can't trust men saying men
are idiots saying if you give all your
the authority to men they will abuse it
yes yeah even though they really run the
whole infrastructure of society they
really do you know Society we could not
survive without men yet yet the women
will say oh oh the men just will abuse
me oh oh submitting to the crazy thing
is they'll submit to a boss but not a
husband that's what baffles me that's
what blows my mind they'll listen to
their boss but if I say would you listen
to your husband it's crazy
yeah
I once saw you and put a tweet that said
if all women
stop working tomorrow society would
function fine but if all men stop
working tomorrow society would be in
shambles
now
I respect you a lot Pearl
I have to disagree with you here okay
my wife is the sole reason
I am as successful as I am
every morning she makes me a cup of tea
and gives me a [__]
now then I start my work
now I could go without the cup of tea
but without that [__]
I wouldn't be as motivated to work as
hard to finish my day and to come back
home
to get some more
right so
that's actually one of my African rules
as well
that
a great woman Miss Alpha King 202
a great woman will help you become
successful a lot easier
yeah so when I tweeted that I said
outside of reproduction now so what I
was saying basically now okay we could
talk about the emotional the motivation
fine but what I'm talking about is
women's jobs
our women's jobs the infrastructure of
society would it still run and they've
kind of done this experiment right they
put women on an island and they need to
be saved within like two days and they
put men on an island and they kind of
have a little Society Running now I'm
not saying you know we probably wouldn't
have the vacuum cleaner like come on men
made that for women there's some
inventions we wouldn't have but I do
think if women disappeared tomorrow
outside of reproduction and like the
feelings and stuff Society could still
run like men would figure out how to be
nurses men would figure out how to be
assistants but women could not figure
out the things that men do
we could not figure out the plumbing
have you ever seen a girl trying to
cheat you're telling me okay it took
like 10 chicks to change a a car tire
yeah and that we could figure out the
power line yeah so a lot of people took
that as like the motivation and stuff
I'm not really talking about I I
understand that like women assist men
like all that that's good and dandy I
just meant like our jobs we we monetize
Beauty a lot and so we think that our
jobs are more important than they really
are when it comes to the infrastructure
of society not saying there aren't
exceptions but it's like we didn't need
women
to run Society for most of History
what's different now now there were
always exceptions you know of high IQ
women like Cleopatra Joan of Arc that
you know made waves in society right you
know there were women that did but when
it comes to like a would everything
still run probably yeah that's a good
point
yeah so I'm not I'm not talking about
I'm not talking about motivation yeah
yeah yeah I understand men are motivated
by the women yes women are good Mothers
we need them I'm not but I'm saying like
to run the whole system yeah it's a fair
point I mean it is something to be said
about
it is there is something to be you know
it's crazy I started I started
researching the industries that women
run they're all the ones we complain
about
no I know I care I swear I
would they all the industries are like
that has gone off the rails education
Women
Health Care women
the DMV 's like 90 women there's nothing
we complain about more than the DMV
because when women go into things we
want equality we don't really want to
reward competencies we want things to be
fair and equal We're Men they want the
smartest people to win yeah yeah and
they kind of respect each other for it
we're women it's like if we get higher
on like the attention hierarchy then
women will like tear down other women so
they can get higher you feel women tear
you down oh my gosh yes and it comes
everywhere oh my goodness and they they
call me they say I hate women that I you
know I just sit on women all day when
I'm just trying to describe Society what
I can say is the more reproductive
Freedom we've gotten hasn't gone well
for us the more we've come you know if
you look at the chart of women in the
workforce and the number of regulations
like if women went home tomorrow we
could fire all the HR departments
we could fire with everybody like I
honestly think it'd be more productive
not less now
it's not to say there's not exceptions
you know I love I love Megan Kelly you
know I'm not I'm not against you know
women doing certain things but I think
when we start to run Industries
problems come and then I started
women do better than men and I really I
couldn't think of anything now I'll
explain to you why I was thinking we can
cook better no all the top Michelin
chefs were men and I was like well we're
better parents but single father homes
are better than single mother homes I
was
really I spent a whole day trying to
think of something but when there's like
money involved
men just win they just always win now
this isn't to say that women have no
value I'm a woman you know what I mean
but I
I just was looking at the numbers yeah
and I was like now men are even more
pure than women imagine that's like what
we're supposed to bring Purity now we
have more male versions than female I
was like I can't think of anything
it's Unique coming from you too because
you actually
you know are a successful entrepreneur
yes and you actually and you have a good
relationship with your dad and you know
and you went to college and you could
have gone and become a pro athlete and
here you are saying this oh yeah you
know it's like it's sort of like you are
the poster child of
what they would probably hate a lot of
these women well I'll tell you what this
we would have been broke six mom just a
woman we just like to swipe the credit
card right you know what I mean and I'm
not a big spender on material stuff but
you see all the equipment around here
very nice right I would have went broke
six months ago if my dad wasn't like
whoa whoa whoa slow your horses you
can't just spend all the money you you
know what I mean and you know I'm really
lucky where I have guys to help me but
if it was just me on my own Consulting
with women oh we would not be here we
would not be here so I think a lot of
times what you'll find is women that do
Succeed in Business have a lot of smart
men around them definitely Kim
Kardashian yes you know she became a
billionaire with Kanye yeah yeah you
know you're telling me and it's
interesting we look at all the top
females and I was thinking about this
like Kylie Jenner versus Elon Musk who
is one is that's a good point Twitter a
lot he's he's pushing Society forward
Kylie Jenner is also a billionaire now
you could say she's not as rich but
she's just the first famous example I
could think of
what is she she's selling makeup what is
advancing Civilization now again
this isn't to say women have no value
but it's less than we think and I also
realize that all of these men
are really paying for our jobs because
they have all these grants to like push
us in the workforce they're really just
taking money from the men and giving it
to the women and monetizing Beauty so I
don't think we're as important as we
think yeah and the women just don't like
it when I say this and I'll say this as
me and I even thought of myself and I
was thinking I'm like me I have a
podcast and I was like Myron had to be a
federal agent he had to like coach men
for all these years and I was thinking
of Brian who does whatever and I was
like he was a YouTuber for a decade I
just brought some mics and started doing
my thing you know and I was like it's
really an example of female privilege
now this isn't to say I don't work hard
or do a good job but I think we can we
can acknowledge that women especially
when we're young have a privilege in the
workforce
yeah I mean I I will say though out of
out of the women that I've seen on
social media I think to your credit
you've really done well like you like
thank you thank you yeah like to get
have this studio and you know not just
here but like even what I saw before we
start filming like the team you have and
that that's organizational ability
that's like not just influencer social
media that's like you're actually a
legitimate business person thank you
thank you I I think so too you took the
risk I I did the risk is the price
growth correct correct but but I still
was thinking about it and to say I had
no Advantage because I'm a woman it's
silly you know I I definitely did to get
here I mean the fact that you got this
place it's a big place it's just one
room the equipment the staff you have
here security everything like you have a
full team yeah you basically built a TV
studio and uh that really is
entrepreneurship yeah you know what I
mean that's really like the people that
just have one business they just work
alone they're a freelancer right right
so like in 2027 freelancer will actually
be like the most
popular job most of our Workforce will
be freelancer within a few years really
you think so yeah that was according to
a study I think in the Wall Street
Journal or something like wow it was a
prediction the trend we're already
getting there okay but like the idea of
being an entrepreneur and being able to
have an organization and be able to
create jobs have Labor
you know being able to distribute
Capital make investments
manage manage accounting all of this
stuff the taking a risk what happens if
I purchase all this stuff and it doesn't
work out
putting it together figuring it out
all of that stuff this we're not even
talking about entrepreneurship right
you'll see a lot of people that do well
on tick tock
and outside of being able to get you
know money from Brand deals or
sponsorship they're going to struggle
because
you know they they haven't on Tick Tock
they might have got hand out by the
extreme far left staff there but once
they get off that ocean once they go
into another platform once the tide
turns on a lot of these creators and
influencers where they lose that one
stream of monetization you're going to
see who's actually an entrepreneur
and who's not you know like it's easy to
copy Mr Beast many people copy Mr Beast
yeah but but here's the beauty of Mr
Beast but Mr Beast did I think
the real secret was that he did
something new yeah he did and like and
like I think even if everyone copied him
today that well guess what happens it
loses its value you you lost the
competitive value once everybody knows I
think his level of Mastery is so
significant on YouTube for example that
he can have everyone copy just as an
experiment for him to learn just to set
up the next new thing he's going to do
which is going to be nothing like what
the others are going to do right it's
like that level of Mastery yeah you know
what I'm saying and that happens in all
Industries so as soon as you feel like
someone's copying you you pivot look I
did millions of dollars of business over
20 years you go on Money Twitter their
average experience is three years of
business they're giving business advice
like it's Bill Gates or Elon Musk or
Warren Buffett or Mark Cuban you know
over 20 years of business experience
doing millions of dollars at deals I
don't become multi-millionaire on Tick
Tock you know I was already doing
Millions before I got on Tick Tock and
I'll tell you in in business this is
from a man with over 20 years of
experience
you're going to have good cycles and
tough Cycles
not everyone makes it through a tough
cycle
you know and you're going to have
competitors that are going to copy you
no matter what business you go to your
competition will watch you
for Content creators it's okay they can
copy me XYZ
they're watching my videos they're
watching my stories but no matter what
business you go to your competition will
watch you that's just and that's that's
just business right right you know what
I mean that's why I don't I think the
worst content oh my gosh I have a rant I
have a rant the credit police oh my gosh
everyone like you know what I realized
so Kevin Samuels I like was such a big
fan of and I noticed there's so many
people that would like say they were
credited for his ideas like I have heard
this from like five different people and
I was like it's so interesting in
YouTube the the people that are really
like pushing forward like the space
they're never concerned about credit or
copycats they're just doing their own
thing but I realize everyone that's like
oh they copied me they copied me one
nobody's copying you yeah yeah and and
two if you're worried about you're like
focusing on the wrong thing you need to
worry about like making new and
Innovative content you know it's such a
it's such a good it's man that's such a
good point because there was like five
different people I swear there's like
five different people I heard say that
they were the reason Kevin Samuels had
his show and I was just like he's not
doing the same thing any of you guys are
doing yeah I guarantee I guarantee you
if you have anybody that watches this
show that grew up with a father in
particular from a Mediterranean country
uh
Middle Eastern country Latin American
country
uh you know African country got more
water oh yeah yeah yeah well
I was getting dehydrated yeah it's
pretty hot in here yeah I was getting
dehydrated but sorry go ahead take care
of my bladder they won't do that if
they're from a Mediterranean country
yeah I guarantee you any man okay who
who has a father from a Mediterranean or
Middle Eastern country right like
you you probably grew up like I did
where you had masculinity so like my
father to his credit a lot of the stuff
that's popular now on this red pill or
you know Alpha stuff on so she just
taught you yeah my father's been like my
father was to me since the 90s I was
learning this stuff especially as a
middle eastern Mediterranean and this
stuff was just normal right so like if
someone says to me I copied so I'm like
bro I'm like I'm older than almost all
of you and my father in his 70s is the
one if I'm going to give anyone credit
it's my father and his friends because
this is just a cultural norm in that
region of the world right you talk to
any guy from Spain Italy Lebanon Egypt
Israel Iran you know like you go to
Greece you go to Turkey you know you
know in these countries these men
there's not Albania you know you go to
these countries these men have father
others that this is just a cultural norm
right this is nothing like surprising so
what's your advice to guys that want to
succeed in business and like make it
through those rough patches especially
now because there's so many people
wanting to do content creation or like
freelance Drop Shipping whatever it is
yeah I would I would say like the the
number one thing I'd say is try out a
bunch of things that will work for you
and you like rather than just trying to
do something you don't like and your dad
told me the same thing yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's crazy some people one person
tagged me on one of my videos today
and said uh and they tagged someone
and they were like
hey Shelly he looks like your dad
you know and I was just like wow I look
like some girl's dad who's watching my
video you know no no way yeah yeah so
just when you say that you know so so
try you know it really is there's
something to be said about trying out
what works for you and that you actually
like rather than trying to do what you
think will make you a lot of money and
you hate if you can if you can get two
checks on that check box you like it and
you're good at it you significantly have
a benefit that is so funny that is
literally exactly what my dad told me
like three years ago because I quit I
was I was working in copy yourself
and I quit it to do I was like I had one
viral Tick Tock and it was it was
actually just me telling a story about
my family like it was actually nothing
to do with any because I had a whole
following I built off of like no red
pill like that's why people are like oh
you're just like grifting pandering I'm
like you know how much more money I
would have made doing it to women oh my
God yeah we were talking about earlier
but but
so
um yeah my dad always said like I don't
care if you make sandwiches or sell
toothpicks on the side of the road like
do something you love and do it well
because there aren't that many people
that really try and are smart at the
same time so he would always say like if
you do something you love you're gonna
put in so many more hours than everybody
else and it was so true because a lot of
people will kind of I guess criticize me
because they'll be like oh you work so
much but it's like it doesn't feel like
work a lot of the time because I
genuinely love doing it like it's just
it's like I'd rather I would rather do a
podcast than go to a party like it's
just more fun to me yeah yeah even the
whole um the whole I'm sorry the whole
premise of my show was started because
um like my show is called the pregame
and it was the whole idea was I always
like pre-games better than parties
because you would have like such a deep
conversations with people yeah and like
in a party it's loud everyone's taught
like I just didn't like parties so the
whole premise was the pregame is better
than the party and I was playing sports
or so it's kind of like a double on you
know
um but it's funny my dad really said the
same thing to me um and he thought it
was nuts when I was like yeah Dad I'm
gonna be a tick tocker but he's like if
you like it try it do it while you're
young man that's great you know
it's interesting too how your dad said
your your dad said to you if you sell
toothpicks or toothbrushes whatever make
sure you love it I I call this uh the
Kimberly example
Kimberly makes it's disgusting but when
you go to the bathroom at like an
airport okay you see the toilet paper
and then you see the dispensary
dispensary says Kimberly that's a
company okay the owner of that company
makes a lot of money
right but what it but is that person
passionate about selling toilet
dispensary
probably not yeah right but he finds
honor in his work he may have other
motivation to his work and I guarantee
you he's taking care of his family okay
this is the
um we're just talking about this the
other day how men will do jobs because
they feel like no one else will do them
where women will not
so like like if I don't do the sewers or
the elect the power lines like all that
stuff is that like the A1 job where you
get the most recognition and honor in
society no but it's like a lot of guys
realize that no one else will do the job
if they don't
and I feel I feel like that about I feel
it's interesting that's a good point I
feel like that about
I feel like when we're in a culture with
such a high level of degeneracy yeah
I can either make entertainment
or I can make educational content
uh but I I want to defend a group that's
being largely overlooked
and I feel like if I get canceled again
completely canceled and even if and it
sounds cliche but one person sees it
five ten people see it more people will
see it than that
but then it's like I'm one more person I
got canceled
out of a list of people that got
canceled and maybe they don't see me
again
maybe I quit but they saw that I did it
my way and I refused to surrender my art
or if I'm doing education or politics My
Views I respect people who stand on
their feet
and they say what they say and they mean
it for example
what I don't respect I've talked about
this before okay
there was a company Bud Light in the
United States
yeah yeah and they had that tran girl
right but hold on no I'm gonna I'll tell
you something all right all right so
first of all I think clearly the CEO is
a [__] for picking her because he
didn't he didn't understand his his
audience right
but what really made me lose respect for
him on a high level
was the fact that after Delvin or
whatever the trans name is she was
getting death threats
and she was scared to leave her home
they basically abandoned her
and she made a point of like why did you
even book me
if you're not going to support me so it
tells me it's two sides why I lost
respect for Bud Light one
they really they like the CEO didn't
understand his buyer
why even Booker right you know they're
gonna they're not gonna like it they
want to buy your beard they want to see
a guy on a [__] Cowboy right
anyone see a guy on a horse you know
they don't understand that they don't
that's not they don't want that but if
you did it
at least [__] standby right you know
what I mean now it tells me that Bud
Light executive team was fake across the
board they were fake when they promoted
her from an ideological level social you
know virtue signaling um right because
as soon as they didn't make money they
don't want a virtue signal and then
after they damaged that person who's
scared to walk outside because they're
fearful fearful of violence then they
abandon her and don't even give her
let's say security for a few months so
it tells me complete it's it's complete
playing the moral Authority virtue
signaling
on all levels and not standing for what
you believe you know how crazy it is you
know how crazy this is the trans people
have come to England yeah I in the
volleyball leagues and I I said yeah
yeah I'm like this is the you have the
wrong [__] like I like it looky look it
look it I know maybe the the super
feminine traditional woman would just
say oh and not say anything that's not
me sorry guys sorry guys yeah so I went
to this tournament there's a whole team
full of them
wow yeah yes and I wasn't even a funny
thing I didn't even I played in this
tournament the year before but this year
I forgot to sign up so my friend was
playing in it and and um yeah and I said
something to the tournament director I'm
like you you know this is wrong right
there's no way you're like you're in
your 40 like and that's the crazy thing
I'm like these people are so much older
than us
and I'm like how now women you can
propagate women like I think it's been
really clear that women just eat
propaganda I mean why do you think we go
with the latest fashion trends every
year they'll convince us to wear like
these did they they convinced us to wear
puff sleeves puff sleeves like they'll
they'll convince us to I mean you see
the [__] they have us by every okay if
they can convince us to wear anything
they can convince women to believe
anything too so when women believe crazy
things okay but when I see grown men
that are my father's age with a lifetime
of experience too afraid to like say
anything about this stuff I'm just
thinking what on Earth and I said that
Tim I'm like you know this is wrong and
he's like well volleyball England said
said this to me and I'm like well but
you know this is you know this isn't
right they're in I just went in the
locker room they're in there like you
know that's not right that we have to
share our locker rooms with men you know
that's wrong and he it was so crazy like
seeing like the NPC or whatever you call
it just come out where he's like well I
want everyone to be included and I'm
just looking at him like no you don't I
know you I know that you know this is
crazy that's an NPC yeah and so I was
like can you do an interview about it no
no and now they're they're I'm probably
gonna get I'm on like some disciplinary
hearing I don't care whatever that's the
thing I'm one of the best volleyball
players in England so I'm just like not
that it takes much England is not good
at volleyball but I'm like I'm like you
guys are lucky I'm even here get out of
here so so but then the second part the
second part was um
yeah they um they said my tweets are
transphobic and they're saying you
cannot release the footage that you took
interviewing girls at that tournament
isn't that crazy and I'm just thinking
like I never thought in my lifetime I
would have a problem playing with trans
people because it was like the Next
Generation that was doing it but I'm
like Jesus I cannot believe
and I guess there were some in the
normal season too I just didn't notice I
didn't that's a crazy thing [__] man
that's that is that is that's crazy so
you so you've played game you've played
matches against men apparently I didn't
notice but because some of them the
funny thing is when I was watching them
play was that they'll like hit hard like
too hard and they'll like back off like
it's like they see the man come out of
them and then they'll like back off to
blend in it's so weird it's so it's such
a weird phenomenon they'll like do
something masculine and they'll be like
oh wait I'm supposed to be feminine dang
yeah that's crazy the crazy thing is
that the there was the film because it
was an all nations tournament so it was
the Philippines and Brazil they had all
the trans people on them I don't know
what it is about those two countries
yeah yeah yeah yeah the Philippines was
the worst they had like five and I was
like the Philippines still lost really
that was part of like imagined you're
like cheating and you're still losing oh
the Brazilians were doing well though
because they had like one tall dude he
was just hitting everything they were
sending them every time they won the
championship I don't know I didn't stay
till the end I just got my footage and
so the next day was Sunday so I went to
church that day so I was like yeah I was
like I'm not wasting my day on these
trans but it's just crazy it shows how
far the like world has come like it is
crazy in an average like tournament in
England now we have men playing and we
have grown men co-signing this and the
women cosign it too but it's it's just
mad and I mean the thing is that women
don't have that problem know that men
don't have that problem of women
competing in their sport
so it's sort of like a two-way street
right like it's sort of like not two-way
street but it's not a two-way street
rather it's a one-way street where the
men can do that to women's sports
but but the but the women aren't going
to men's sports so for example it's no
one's and I'm sure you've heard that
people say this like it's not women that
are going crazy and doing the sex stuff
in front of the kids it's men that are
doing it and you know what's really
scary as a father of a daughter
is the idea that if she's 16 years old
or 13 years old a man going into a
woman's bathroom
hey that's just like come on man like
like how did the fathers like me lose
their how about like like you know like
I really like like at what point do we
just say like my 13 year old daughter I
gotta worry about
she goes to the mall my wife
then there's a 45 year old guy in there
who wants to rape her let's just be
[__] graphic because this happens you
know
she can't go to the bathroom but if I
even talk about this
I'm actually a homophobe how about I'm
just a father this is the this is the
level of indoctrination by the way it's
so [__] the indoctrination is so Peak
right now that a father saying he
wouldn't want his daughter who's 13
let's say when she's 13. and I am a
father of a daughter that I wouldn't
want my daughter to go to a bathroom
that a man uses
and pretends to be a woman and we both
know there are men who do that to go
rape women
that's a fact that's a fact that there's
not going to get shown that there are
men
that are going to say oh yeah but that
only happened 10 times yeah but it's ten
times too many why why do we have to be
the experiment but it's like you said
but it's like you said earlier like I
don't even see or someone said to me
earlier like I don't even see gay people
but I'm seeing all these gay flags so
the trans Community is already very
small
right so you it's not supposed to be
that you see it every day so when you
consider if you saw that 10 10
situations in the news
that's already a lot considering how
small that Community is proportionate to
it but the bottom line
I think if you took a poll of men
real men not men that wear you know red
lipstick and dresses not men that carry
their wife's purse you know what I'm
saying like men men you ask a hundred
men
hey do you want your daughter to go to
the bat when she's under 16 years old do
you want your daughter to go to the
bathroom a public bathroom that a man
can dress as a as a woman he could rape
her you don't have to worry about that
when you're at work I guarantee you I
guarantee you at least
70 out of 100 men and I'm saying this is
America where you got so much liberals
I'm just saying even 60 out of 100 men
if not 90 out of 100 men would say to
you I don't feel comfortable and I don't
want to worry about my daughter getting
raped
in a public bathroom I got enough
problems on my mind right and I'm not a
bigot and I'm not a homophobe and I
respect everyone and I'll teach my
daughter to respect everyone of all
walks of life I really will you know
have gay friends I'm not bigot I'm just
saying I don't want a man to be able to
go into a bathroom with my daughter if
she's 13 years old I think it's
disgusting
and I think if the mall really cares
about it they will open up another
bathroom that's unisex I think any
establishment that wants to do it okay
fine open up a unisex bathroom also but
don't but don't make it men or women if
you're going to play that game the
government's going to play woke
okay play woke create another bathroom
I mean how much but they don't even want
to do that it's like why do I
why do I believe in there
like I don't want to cater to it at all
like okay men hear women here end of
story stop arguing that's it I don't
care if you dress like a man I don't
care if you dress like a woman boys and
girls and it's crazy because I just
can't believe they're throwing this onto
the children they're like we need to
educate the kid what do you mean educate
the kids do like that's what I don't
like any of this stuff where like the
school comes in and gets to play parrots
that's why I don't even like sex ed I'm
like get this set why did you get to
pick when the kids need to know about
sex that's the parents because every
kid's different you don't know when and
every kid You could argue that maybe
they need to know what this stuff is
because the world's crazy and you can't
Shield them from the world fine but the
parents should decide at what age the
pair the kids if they need to be opened
up to that and that's what irritates me
is they they want the state to play
parents
get get out these crazy bathrooms I
don't and I said this to a room full of
trans people yes you really you know it
Pearl I don't wanna I don't want to live
in their delusion at all your father did
a great job raising you I mean you
really should keep going with what
you're doing because you're bringing a
lot of common sense back it's not even
like it's really just like you're really
just saying so it's so good to hear a
woman talk like well you know what's
funny it's funny I'm supposed to be a
liberal you know yeah my my personality
traits I took the test the Jordan
Peterson test it says like 90 chance I'm
gonna be liberal I was so mad when I
took it that I took it again
I will say though you are pretty liberal
in the sense of what people don't see
this and you hire diversity yeah and
that way you are a liberal yeah well
it's not like everyone here is blonde
blue eyes yeah well and Liberals are
more like open to new experiences like
there's like traits like my dog's
friendly like when a liberal buys a dog
they buy like a friendly dog where a
conservative buys a dog it like is a
guard dog yeah so there are certain
traits but you're right my dad every
time I would come home with like a crazy
I mean we're so easy to propagate women
so like it happened to me too I'd go to
I went to a college one of the first
colleges to have trans people there was
trans people on my floor oh my gosh I
know and this is the crazy I wasn't
really that political back then because
I was so into volleyball I just didn't
have time right but volleyball is very
left too it's a very left sport so it's
as I have two conservative parents
they're fighting a losing battle like do
you know what I mean like I'm on Tick
Tock laughed I go into a volleyball left
I go to school like it was just such I
did study economics
about what happened I would go home oh I
would go home to my dad and he would
just dispel every crazy idea I had
because for a while I felt bad my dad's
a very successful guy he had um 200
employees he had a software company very
very successful hard-working guy and I
would feel bad because I would be like I
have so many advantages I have no
college debt and I would genuinely feel
guilty about like having so much
privilege in the world and so I would
like one thing I remember you talked me
out of was these free government
programs and not not that you can't have
any but I would be like Dad why can't we
help everyone you know and he just
looked at me he says two dollars and one
dollar out and I was like huh no no no
no you put two dollars into something
you make one dollar you can only have so
many programs like that until you run
out of money
and it was very simple right because
like the government is like all
confusing all the programs whatever but
my dad would just talk me out of all
this stuff he would just sit there for
two hours where I would say Dad this is
a great idea and he would just tell me
why it was in fact not a great idea
that's pretty cool though yeah yeah
when you meet your husband
uh
uh I assume you're a straight woman oh
yeah I'm very straight yeah okay yeah
like very like none of this like but I
know all the women are like bisexual
nowadays all that craziness no not me
everyone yes Mommy I'm a tomboy I'm I am
a bit of a tomboy
but none of that nonsense I mean I mean
just saying you know objectively I'm
married man but objectively speaking you
know tall well you're five eleven yeah
five eleven and a half yeah you know I'm
an athlete I like this you're like a
model tall you know models are that tall
you know what I mean yeah yeah I mean
yeah so so like okay so you're tall
you're successful you're intelligent
you're responsible
and when you meet your husband
and I say this also for firsthand
experience my wife's father is a CEO in
the auto sector he has factories he does
he does manufacturing for auto companies
and he's on the board of directors of a
professional soccer team
Bundesliga and I admire him
I admire my wife's father and when you
meet your husband Pearl
he's Pro you know like especially if he
has an interest in entrepreneurship even
if he doesn't but like when my wife's
father so successful he's like well
known in our city in Germany and um when
I'm with him I sort of like I'm like wow
I'm with him his name is Martin I'm like
I'm with Martin like he's just like six
foot four Viking yeah looking guy and um
I just I admire him a lot
and I think that whatever husband you
get
uh it's gonna you're gonna really you
just the way you think your dad's so
cool and he's this big businessman your
husband will probably like that too
yeah hopefully yeah yeah he will I yeah
I remember me saying that it's really
important to me that like a guy I date
like I've actually I've broken up with
people because my dad didn't like them
yes but he wants the best for you yeah
that's what I figure whether you trust
your dad yeah well I figured I'm like
women we have horrible mate selection
horrible like if you look at the more
Choice we've gotten as women in the last
hundred years we've gotten like we used
to live with our our fathers until we
got married so before like a hundred
years ago the 20s is when women started
to like live on their own in apartments
our main selection like look at the
marriage rate since women have had more
Choice it's horrible yeah so I'm like
I'm a woman we're so susceptible to
propaganda you know we were susceptible
to the sweet talk I gotta you dad's
gotta get involved I love that I'm gonna
have my wife I don't know if she's
watching but uh I'm gonna tell her that
we're gonna watch this this part I love
what you just said yeah about the
daughter of being at home until she gets
married I want I love that idea I want
my daughter to do that it worked better
it worked better when we did that if you
look at the more Choice women have
gotten and made selection it's gotten
horrible there's a reason that there was
like the the women the fathers were like
stay away from that boy because the
women love you know the bad guy but the
guy the dad knows that well yeah but
they'll like lock you in your room you
know they're like no no that's true
because when you when you were a baby
and I guarantee you have the pictures of
when you were a baby an infant your
father maybe kissed your cheeks played
with your hair look at you in your eyes
maybe did a bath with you washed you
changed maybe you know maybe I don't do
the diaper part but at least I help with
the bathroom yeah yeah uh and uh
you know you're you're so precious to
your dad and uh there's no way another
man I even me I like I'm terrified of
anything happening to me one reason I
decided to get healthier after the
lockdown I gained wait
I I lost a lot of my good habits now
I've lost the weight that I gained
during the lockdown but I realized that
I'm not Invincible I got sick I realized
I wasn't I wasn't Invincible like I was
when I was younger
and the idea that I won't be alive from
my daughter is terrifying to me you know
and because I love her so much and the
idea of other men abusing her just
tortures me inside and out and I hope
that she never pays the price for the
things I've done to women because now I
look back on women and I think oh I used
to just have her come over and I would
[__] her and then I would take a shower
and I'd be done and my goal would be
within like 30 minutes of her coming
over
in and out we [__]
I take a shower
she leaves
I finished it all within 30 minutes now
I look back on that and think
how much she how did she feel
that I would she might have actually
really liked me and here I was just
[__] her as soon as I'm done [__]
her I'm going and taking a shower then
I'm asking her basically to leave or in
a polite way very polite way I'm walking
around taking her going I'm taking her
out now I think is am I going to pay the
price
with dealing with the torture of another
man doing that to the most precious
thing that I have in this world
which is my daughter
I hope not I hope she doesn't pay the
price for what her father did but I'll
tell you this much
um your father you are precious to him
in a way that it's I'm telling you you
know you you're dead you know you you're
you're you're his daughter you know
you're his daughter
you he knew you and you were an infant
Earl he knew you when you were one hour
old there's no way that he would want
you to be with a man that's going to
disrespect you and hurt you he's
thinking of your future 50 years from
now after he dies he's thinking of a man
that's going to protect you
when he's gone in this cold vicious
World
brutality you know he's thinking like
I'm telling you because I'm a father
what a daughter he wants someone that's
going to protect you like a warrior a
gladiator
you know a hunter
because he's gonna he's gonna die one
day and you're going to be alone he
knows that he has that responsibility in
his heart deep in his brain so when he
does that it's almost like his longevity
plan it's almost like the CEO exiting
and saying another CEO is going to come
I want to make sure it's the handoff to
I'm giving my daughter to a man that's
going to take care of her
do you think because it's interesting
one thing you said was that like the
womanizing right yeah and you said that
you would pay the price someday are you
you're afraid you would pay the price
someday
I don't think do you think it's the
man's responsibility to keep the sexual
Marketplace pure because I almost think
it's like kind of on the women because
we're in control of sex men are in
control of relationships so I don't
really even fault guys that womanize
because it's kind of like if she doesn't
do it with you she's going to do it with
someone else
yeah I mean I that's kind of the way I
think I do think it's a I do have all
also noticed that men that do women eyes
tend to get daughters I don't know what
it is I tell you I tell you I've seen
that in the space all the guys that like
would brag about the sex stuff or like
even just talk about it maybe not even
brag I'm like their first board's always
a daughter I don't know I almost feel
like
if you have a pronoun bio you know how
people say like uh opinion invalid you
know like there's like like you see that
on social media like in the comments
yeah yeah yeah I would say to me to me
if a man gives me advice on women
and I see that he's not actually a
father to a daughter
it's I'm not going to say opinion
invalid but man if you didn't cross the
river
you don't know what it's like you gotta
cross the river you gotta tell me that I
I want to know for at least six months
of your life you've held an infant
daughter baby girl in your arms and that
if that didn't affect you you're a
[__] psychopath you know what I'm
saying like like you don't experience
love I want to experience love I live
with passion I love my daughter with
passion you know I'm here with passion I
drink the water with passion I make love
to my wife with passion I work in my
business with passion I eat with passion
I try to live with passion you know your
dad loves you with passion that he gets
involved and he tries to help you and
correct you he lives with he loves you
with passion
he probably understands that you know he
understands so you know I
think to myself I hope my daughter
doesn't pay the price for what I did and
I also think that when you see in young
men talk about women in a highly
disrespectful way and this is coming
from me look how much I you know I'm not
exactly some I don't hold my wife's
purse I refuse you know earlier today I
watched this guy this guy was holding
his wife's purse I was just like bro
like you you're letting her dominate you
when you do that [__] you know what I'm
saying then I saw
and I just I just I just thought to
myself I'm like
and I was like is it my ego but I'm like
I can't my wife knows I'll carry
anything for her I'll carry a sofa floor
before I carry the purse you know no
really and I'll never change and I
almost never will change the diapers I
just first of all I feel uncomfortable
changing the diapers of my daughter
because I feel like it's almost
pedophilia I almost feel like
like playing with my daughter's area
it's it's it's so disgusting to me that
that it's like like I like pedophilias
deserve to be locked up forever first of
all but but I couldn't even I couldn't
even touch her like that because it
would creep me out I was like so it's
not out of disrespect to my wife that
I'm like I'm not gonna change her
diapers it's just out of like the
pedophilia stuff it's just too close to
that you know I'll do everything else
with my daughter I'll take a bath with
my daughter I'll hold her in bed I'll do
all those things but I'm not gonna
change her diaper and clean her little
area you know that that makes me feel
very uncomfortable to be honest with you
but that being said to the original
point
look when once you have a daughter
okay
oh I [__] a lot of women okay fine you
[__] 100 200 300 women okay you got
that out you've already proven everybody
you [__] women on television you [__]
fashion models you [__] influencers
okay great you got that all out
okay
clap for the person
have you able to experience being
married
to one woman for a while have you been
able to experience having a daughter
then give me then talk to me about women
you know then I I would say okay now
your opinion has the heaviest weight Ray
dalio hedge fund manager talks about
believability you know if a janitor is
talking to you
about the variety of disinfectants and
sanitation methods of XYZ product
that person has more weight on their
opinion than the chef in the restaurant
who doesn't handle Sanitation
but the chef has more credibility and
believability when it comes to sourcing
ingredients from specific Farmers with
specific vegetable gardens and fruit
trees herbs seeds right recipes cooking
material right so not everyone everyone
has an opinion but not everyone's
opinion has the same value
you know so I say that to say this
I've basically gone to the other side to
say I did I was a sex addict I [__] a
lot of women and I was a dog
I'm not proud of it because now I got a
daughter
and I and it and I and it lives with me
you know lives with me but I think what
another man could do to my daughter
scares the [__] out of me you know so
what your father is doing by being close
with you man you know how deep the game
is how about the game of a father with
his daughter you talk about game with a
guy [__] a woman at a nightclub how
about the game of a guy with his
daughter look how strong your father's
game is
think how strong your father's game is
that he tactfully did that he said you
said I'm going to come back home Dad
after many years
and your dad says happily Oh Come Back
makes you feel warm and welcomed to the
point where you recite the story to me
yeah he knew Pearl he understood the
significance of you coming back he saw
that as an opportunity to make you feel
loved also feel welcomed and accepted
for just for being who you are that's
one of the best things he did to help
you
put Place yourself at a high level
if he doesn't do that for you then
you're not going to Value yourself now
to your earlier point it's my last Point
yeah when you said is it the woman's
responsibility Pearl and I say this
respectfully you have a great dad
you know you have a dad that loves you
and welcomes you Embraces you it's it's
it's it's so much harder when you don't
have a I say this as a father with a
daughter that breaks my heart when I
think of women who don't have a father
now doesn't mean I'm Captain Save A Hoe
ah name was saying go save a [__] no
I'm not right you know like I'm not but
what I'm saying is
there is a degree of empathy to say hey
she didn't have that other girl doing
that She's suffering way more than
giving up her body and her [__] right
her pain is deeper than giving up her
[__] her that surface level I don't
know because I just I'm sorry I think
I'm desensitized because all the shows
I've done I don't really I don't think
there's much remorse anymore the women
the women yeah I don't really think I
don't even really think it's like a dad
thing I mean the dad thing like makes it
worse but I see it from girls from two
parent homes I see it for like I see it
everywhere I think it's like social
media in the culture because again women
are so easy to propagate
the propaganda it's so strong it is so
strong that like it because again like
if we see that other women are rewarded
for being hoes we just like do it you
know cardi B you know Megan the style
and we call it Kim Kardashian all the
high status I can't think of one high
status pure woman out of 10 women that
you have you know it's interesting you
say desensitized yeah
I because I felt desensitized working in
a nightclub I felt desensitized to more
women I was [__] I used to call my
old apartment with my roommate yeah
brothel because him and I he was working
as a bar manager I was working as a
nightclub promoter but we were both he
was a tall Dutch guy yeah yeah we were
just bringing back so many women [__]
them that it felt like a brothel it
didn't feel but we were the process yeah
but my point is is that in that period I
didn't feel
um
you know I I like I became desensitized
Pearl So when you say desensitized
because I was desensitized by seeing so
many women lie to me so many women
constantly lie like you talk about a guy
that deals with women that lie yeah
right 25x right on a five day a week but
my thing is I just don't have a lot of
like sympathy like actually women though
yeah why but no but I'm saying but in
the same way of me seeing so many lies
you were seeing when you're seeing women
it makes sense that you're desensitive
yeah because you're seeing these women
come here as a guest yeah you're just
seeing it like 100 x
correct correct So when you say
desensitize that shows that you are able
to have this intuition to say hey I hey
Nema I say this but I may be
desensitized well my whole point my
whole point is this I'm like I wouldn't
even really put it on you if you're like
it's like ah can we really get mad at
the men for screwing a bunch of chicks
when we walk around half naked yeah it's
like all right we
were looking like hookers and then we're
surprised when they treat us like you
would treat a hooker like how crazy it
is it you can't even tell the difference
between a woman in a relationship and a
woman not based on her Instagram and the
way she dresses in modern society I'm
not saying this is a good thing but I
just I I'm curious as to why you feel
like you're gonna like pay for this I
guess because to me it's like they did
it to themselves and a lot of them I I
mean I know some of them it's the dad
thing but these days I see it from the
two parent homes just as much it's like
even when the day like because we're in
the society where you shouldn't listen
to your parents your parents don't know
anything and they go to the college
they're propagated by the colleges and
then you know even when their dad says
you know don't date that guy don't do
that they just don't care they just do
what they want because I'll have all
these girls come on and say I dated the
toxic guy I dated the narcissist and
I'll ask and then first they'll be like
oh he changed though because I was like
well why did you date him right and then
they'll say well you know he changed I'd
be like okay did your dad like him no
your friends like him no and I'm just to
the point where I just got no sympathy I
got none because it's like there could
be warning sign there could be red flag
but I I just this whole put it on the
men for sleeping with us when we look
like prostitutes and act like
prostitutes it's like what what did you
think was gonna happen Diane I'm like
what did you think
Rebecca
like
so do I have a lot of like I mean okay
I'm not gonna say women don't get
bamboozled okay yes yes good women get
bamboozled but
I've seen girls talk about how much they
value sex okay and a guy come on the
show and talk about how he doesn't value
sex
and then that girl goes home with him
and gets mad like you know what I I
don't call people out on their cap on
the show I'm a nice house but I see this
firsthand where I'm like well I got no
sympathy now that he didn't call you
back because I we were just done the
podcast talking about our views on
relationships
like I had one girl come on and talk
about how she was done with the bad boys
right and then she went home with the
ex-felon rapper right after so
and I'm like well now if you don't get
called that now and then okay so then I
was thinking should we put it on the
Felon guy yeah not really because if she
didn't do it with him do you think it
would just be the next felon guy yeah
yeah yeah and if we then it's like okay
if she likes those guys then even if the
guys were like all right let's be nicer
she'd still pick the baddest of the nice
guys so
can I can I blame the men when this is
what we reward
you know and so I really don't think
you'll have Karma I'm gonna be honest
because it's I I I'm sorry you know and
maybe I'm just insensitive because I've
just seen so many things but I think
you'll have no Karma because I really
think that women do this to themselves
yeah I mean sorry sorry this is just my
opinion no with that being said your dad
looks like you did a good job raising
you he did do a good job he did but you
know it would be impossible for me
uh it would be impossible for me as much
as it would be for your dad you know
what I mean like like to sit here and
say
some like like if your father would have
watched me yeah yeah I guarantee you
there's a few things I've said that he'd
be like that was real that was that was
real and he'd say maybe maybe maybe I'm
wrong maybe he'd be like I don't know
why I don't feel like it maybe he would
say I don't I don't I wouldn't word it
the way he worded it but I did you would
agree with a lot of the stuff you said I
think yeah yeah but but my dad's also
from a different time yeah my mom met
when they were young you know they
didn't really go through the crazy stuff
you know yeah but but but like the idea
but like I do think on a deep level your
father didn't raise you to be one of
those women
yeah yeah you know you know he did his
best but you know
you know sir that is a sleeve of tattoos
and blue hair
you know isn't that crazy isn't that
crazy it's like ah dads can only do so
much the culture is strong did he have a
good relationship with her yeah yeah he
did I mean I mean I mean like you well I
mean I am the favorite you know what I'm
saying I like to think I'm the favorite
you know what I mean
oh you know I mean not there we go come
on okay okay there's there's ten of us
they can't we can't all be in the top
half you know yeah but but but it's also
um excluding that little fine print of
what we just said well I mean I'd say he
was still a good dad but it's like I
even had a rebellious you know phase
with my dad too where
I think I was the nicest to him but he
was too logical he would just win I
would be like Dad we're conservative
everything's mean he would just win he's
too logical he has a lot of lack of
sympathy with me too
and it's actually this is why I actually
think we should shame women more for
this because women again we respond
really well to shaming and propaganda
yeah yeah these two things so I think
when you give women too much sympathy
we'll just eat it like we'll take it and
you see it from the nice guys right
because the nice guys give us so much
sympathy and niceness and we just abuse
them we just I'm not saying all women
right but I'm just gonna talk about the
average modern chick right so I don't
know do you disagree with this do you
what do you think no it's just I hope I
I literally think of this and I just
think my daughter one day when she was
26 uh hey you know I really hope my
daughter I think my daughter will be
strong-willed I think she's already
strong she'll be based if she's got she
with your dad she'll be a base yeah yeah
I think she's strong-willed I can tell
your strong willed yeah like she she
does what she wants when she wants yeah
but I feel like when she gets older
she's going to be a tough cookie yeah I
think you're a tough cookie though too
so I think I try to be you're being you
know here we're seeing you as a host of
seeing you in a professional host
setting I'm a guest but I'm just saying
I could tell you're a tough cookie when
it needs to be a tough cookie you know
so what what is a guy as a guy I have a
question so it's a guy you you have your
Alpha Rules right how many Alpha Rules
are there yeah so basically there's a
book that I have that's coming out uh in
September okay and uh you know and and
that's basically rules to help you
transform as a man it's an
unconventional sort of book I don't look
at myself as a as a
traditional CEO in any by any standard
measure
um but it it's just a away from a
married man
as a father has a daughter was an
executive who's created many jobs
and um
just just some rules and I try to do it
in in my own way I had a teacher when I
was young named Mr Brady I think he
passed away I think he might have been
Irish and um he taught math
in a very
unique way that appealed to me
so I try to teach in a way and it was
unique for him and for who he was
so I try to teach in a way that maybe
people on the college campus would
actually like me as a professor
that's it I just try to teach in a way
where the young men would actually uh
like like come to my class
you know and I think there's a plenty I
think there's a lot of people that teach
in a way
where it's boring and they hate going
into class
I just like to teach in a way that
that's my way you know and and uh Alpha
King is really embodies what I more what
I was before I got married my 20s and
30s for men that are still in their 20s
and 30s before they you know they're
going through some things and I think
that a
I like creating
like you Pearl
so why if you had one piece of advice I
know I know you probably get this
question so much we have to pick one one
piece of advice for young guys watching
what would it be big one what's your
number
favorite rule
um I would say my my number one rule is
uh
spend time with your grandmother and
your grandfather because in your 20s and
30s
um they're around
but when you get older you're going to
start losing family members and nobody
Will Smith said no one can hug you to
where your grandma can hug you
that's true I lost my grandma over a
year ago
and she was like a mother to me and um
you know even till this day I can cry
thinking of her
I could never call her
hear her voice
and I never will there's no it's going
to come back
it'll get better
I have to suffer like that forever and
you will too when you lose your grandma
when you lose your grandpa
you're going to lose your parents if
you're lucky that you're going to be
alive if you're not lucky they're going
to watch you die which is even more and
morbid and dark hopefully you take care
of yourself and you're there you're
strong you're able to be there for their
funeral when they can't walk anymore so
the most important advice I would say is
take care of what's most important which
is
you know your family and your health
spend time with your grandma and your
grandpa no amount of money you make is
going to be able to
buy you another hug because once they're
gone they're gone
well thank you very much for coming on
we got to get ready for the show soon
you know
um we got a show tonight where we have
married
um people and single people come on so
it'll be interesting oh that's cool yeah
um so can you tell the people where they
can find you uh yeah you know I at any
point I can get banned uh but uh Nema
n-i-m-a-y-a-m-i-n-i on Twitter Instagram
or just pop that in on YouTube or Tick
Tock you'll see my content
all right guys
um thank you for having me yeah thank
you for coming thank you so much he came
from Germany so thank you very nice to
you to come out um all right guys make
sure you like the video um on your way
out um let's get to a thousand likes on
this video make sure you subscribe to
the channel and tune in tonight
um I we are gonna talk about
hey we're gonna have single our married
people and single mothers on the panel
tonight so it'll be very interesting
like the video on your way out subscribe
to the channel we'll talk to you next
time